E
MEDIA IT WAS THEFT.
FINISH CUSTOMS ADDED THAT THE
ARTWORK WILL BE STORED SAFELY.
U.S. PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS
ACCUSING RUSSIA OF WHAT HE
CALLS MAJOR WAR CRIMES, AFTER
THE BRUTALITY SCENE IN BUCHA,
UKRAINE, AND ANNOUNCED NEW
SANCTIONS TO FURTHER SQUEEZE
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY HE SAYS THAT
THE SANCTIONS WILL FULLY BLOCK
TO OF RUSSIA'S MAIN BANKS
MAKING IT HARD TO INVEST IN
RUSSIA THESE SANCTIONS ALSO
INCLUDE TWO DAUGHTERS OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHO MAY BE
HIDING SOME OF HIS ASSETS.
NINA DOS SANTOS JOINS US FROM
LONDON.
WHEN IT COMES TO SQUEEZING THE
ECONOMY, THE QUESTION IS THE IS
THE SQUEEZE WORTH OF JUICE.
>> THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION,
JOHN.
--
SAYING THAT THIS WAS THE
BIGGEST STEP THUS FAR IN
VARIOUS ROUNDS OF SANCTIONS.
THE EU HAS INTRODUCED AT LEAST
FIVE ROUNDS OF SANCTIONS,
THAT'S FOLLOWED BY MANY
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
BUT I WAS SPEAKING TO EXPERTS
HERE IN LONDON, WHICH FOR THE
LAST 20 YEARS HAS BEEN A BIG
HUB FOR RUSSIAN MONEY, AND
THEY'RE SKEPTICAL AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THIS WILL ACTUALLY APPLY
THAT PRESSURE ON VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S OWN PURSE STRINGS.
>> ANOTHER WEEK ANOTHER
SANCTION ASSETS SEIZED ON
MONDAY SPAIN TO POSSESSION OF
THE SUPER YACHT OWNED BY TYCOON
VICTOR VEKSELBERG, IT FOLLOWS
OTHERS IN FRANCE ITALY IN THE
UK BUT NOW IN THE INVASION
SECOND MONTH EXPERTS
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE PRESSURE
ON RUSSIA'S ONCE OMNIPOTENT
OLIGARCHS IS HAVING A LIMITED
EFFECT.
>> I, FOR, ONE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A MUCH MORE COMMUNITY OF
OLIGARCHS AND USE THEIR
LEVERAGE TO MAKE HIM UNDERSTAND
THE MISERY HE'S INFLUENCING
UKRAINE.
>> DO YOU THINK WE'LL SEE?
THAT >> I THINK IT'S PRETTY
UNLIKELY.
WE SEE WHAT HAPPENS IF PEOPLE
ACROSS VLADIMIR PUTIN, AND
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
SANCTIONED WON'T WANT TO GO THE
SAME WAY.
>> LAST MONTH, RUSSIA'S
PRESIDENT, A MAN ACCUSED OF
POISONING HIS ADVERSARIES,
WHICH HE DENIES, SAYS THAT
TRADERS WILL BE SPED OUT LIKE
FLIES.
THE U.S., THE UK, AND THE EU
HAVE TOGETHER SANCTIONED OVER
1000 RUSSIAN ELITES, AND
DEFENSE FIRMS, MAKING IT
ILLEGAL FOR WESTERNERS TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH CASH OR
SERVICES.
YET, ONLY A HANDFUL OF SO FAR
SPOKEN OUT AGAINST THE
INVASION.
FRIEDMAN AND THE OLYMPIC MEDIUM
MAGNET ARE BOTH UNDER SANCTION,
HAVE BROKEN RANKS WITH THE
KREMLIN, AND CALLED FOR THE
BLOODSHED TO END.
FRIEDMAN, BORN IN UKRAINE, SAYS
HE HAS LIMITED SWAY THESE DAYS.
>> JUST CREATES A NORM US
PRESSURE FOR US PERSONALLY.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE ANY IMPACTS
FOR THE POLITICAL DECISION.
>> THE LINE HAS BEEN THAT THERE
IT IS INNOCENT IN ALL THIS, I
DON'T THINK MANY PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT.
>> FORMER GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
LIKE AND ITALY SO BUYERS HAVE
LET IT BE KNOWN THAT THEY ARE
AGAINST THE EVENTS IN UKRAINE.
NEITHER AGREED TO SPEAK TO CNN
ON CAMERA.
ROMAN ABRAMOVICH HIS ATTEMPTS
TO MEDIATE IN PEACE TALKS,
HASN'T TALKED HIS PRIZE CHELSEA
FOOTBALL CLUB, AND A FLEET OF
BOATS FROM BEEN HIT EITHER, AS
HE TRIES TO SELL THE TEAM.
HE HAS DENIED LINKS TO PUTIN,
SAY NONE OF HIS ACTIVITIES
MERITED SANCTIONS.
>> PUBLIC OPINION IS CERTAINLY
SOURING AGAINST KREMLIN
CONNECTED CASH, ESPECIALLY HERE
IN PRIME PARTS OF CENTRAL
LONDON, THIS MANSION BEHIND ME
WAS BROKEN INTO BY SQUATTERS,
WHO MADE THEIR WAY UP ONTO THE
BALCONY, AND UNFURLED A SIGN IN
PROTEST OF THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
THE REASON THEY SAID THEY
TARGETED THIS PARTICULAR
ADDITIVES, WAS BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVED IT TO BE OWNED BY A
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH.
THAT OLIGARCHY, OLEG DERIPASKA,
RECENTLY SAID THAT ALL SIDES
LOSE OUT, WITH TRAGIC
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
>> I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO
SANCTIONS ON ALL WEEK ARCS,
THERE ARE FRANKLY SYMBOLIC IN
TOTEMIC, THEY KEEP THE ISSUE IN
THE PUBLIC EYE.
>> AND HASN'T SINCE THIS IS A
PR EXERCISE.
>> IT DEFINITELY IS.
>> AUTHORITIES APPEAR TO BE
AWARE OF THIS, ON WEDNESDAY,
U.S. SAID IT WOULD NOW TARGET
THE ASSETS OF PUTIN'S TWO ADULT
DAUGHTERS.
>> ON A DECISION TO --
BERGERON IS OBVIOUSLY A STEP UP
AND MAKING THIS JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE PERSONAL FOR THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT, BUT YOU HAVE
TO REMEMBER THAT HE ALSO
ALLEGEDLY HAS MANY OTHER
CHILDREN, AND HAS A PARTNER
SUPPOSEDLY IN SWITZERLAND, THAT
IS PUTTING BIG PRESSURE ON THE
SWISS GOVERNMENT AS WELL TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT ALLOWING THAT
FAMILY TO STAY IN SWITZERLAND
WHILST THE WAR IN UKRAINE
CONTINUES, JOHN?
>> AND NINA, WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE BIGGER PICTURE WITH
SANCTIONS.
THE RUBBLE FOR EXAMPLE HAS COME
DOWN TO PRE-INVASION VALUE
AGAINST THE U.S. VALUE, SO IT
BOUNCED BACK, IT RAISES A
QUESTION AS TO HOW EFFECTIVE
THESE SANCTIONS ARE IN CHANGING
BEHAVIOR, IF YOU LIKE, ABOUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN IN THE KREMLIN.
>> THAT'S WHY REPEATEDLY YEAR
HERE IN THE THE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY OF UKRAINE CONTINUE
WITH THIS MESSAGE THAT HE
BELIEVES THAT WESTERN POWERS
REALLY NEED TO PRESS THE
ECONOMIC NUCLEAR BUTTON, WHICH
IS TO STOP BUYING ENERGY FROM
RUSSIA.
OF COURSE, RUSSIA IS THE BIG
COMMODITIES MARKET, THIS MEANS
THAT WHEN IT SELLS GAS AND OIL
IT DOESN'T DOLLARS.
ON THE ONE HAND, YOU CAN JUST
LOCK RUSH OUT OF THE RUSSIAN
BANKING SYSTEM, AND IT'S BIG
OLIGARCHY OUT OF THE BANKING
SYSTEM AS WELL.
THE MAIN ASSET TO THIS COUNTRY
CELLS IN DOLLARS AS WELL.
SO, FAR THAT OBVIOUSLY ROOM
REMAINS A PREMATURE ARGUMENT,
AT LEAST IN EUROPE WHERE
GERMANY IS THE BIGGEST ECONOMIC
PLAYER IN THE EU, AND IS SO
HEAVILY RELIANT ON RUSSIA FOR
ITS OIL AND GAS.
YOU ARE STARTING TO SEE THAT
INCREASING RATCHETING UP TO THE
SANCTIONS PRESSURE, FIRST OF
ALL TO TRY TO SQUEEZE OUT THE
OLIGARCH CLASS, GO AFTER
MEMBERS OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
FAMILY AND ALSO GOVERNMENT
MEMBERS AS WELL.
AND, THEN POTENTIALLY, ENERGY
CONTINUES TO BE THE BIGGIE.
JOHN?